you consider yourself a feminist yes or
no Okay so I think that feminism is very
important but I feel like the way it has
manifested in the West in particular is
now causing a net negative and I feel
like that's why conversations right now
are going to be really important to kind
of hold back that sort of Chaos
um so I'd say that I'm a feminist in the
aspect of
women's rights
um however I'm not a feminist
um
the women who go too far with feminism I
think with a lot of women they've been
given an inch and now they want to take
them all so
um that's my perception on it
um I would say I'm a feminist
um and that's because if not for
feminism I wouldn't be here right now
because I'm here because my mum's able
to work as a nurse bring us from Nigeria
and create a life for us so I'm grateful
to feminism for my life basically
um I wouldn't say I'm like in terms of
the new age feminism I do think certain
women go a bit too far like in terms of
promiscuity I I don't feel like they
should use feminism like to justify
promiscuity but I think a lot of women
now they're using feminine feminism as a
way of justifying bad behavior
but feminine as a feminism as a whole I
can't even say it feminism as a whole I
think is very important and it's helped
a lot of women
um come out of abusive situation and
just Empower women generally
yeah I call myself a feminist I think
feminism has done overwhelmingly like
not good uh there might be a couple
crazy people today on like Twitter and
social media but I don't think we should
let that the entire movement I think
it's important to keep moving in a
positive direction forward while calling
out the crazy people that kind of try to
hold things back
I'm an old school feminist women that
know their place
got their rights I know their place
I don't want to be a man I don't want to
be equal to a man
and feminism in the old school days
would nothing like the feminists now so
if I was going to say that I'm a
feminist I would say
I'm an old school feminist and that
these young people who now claim they're
feminists
they're not feminists they want to be
men yeah I agree what's what's changed
from now then to now what's changed is
that they that the lady said that well
she said a mile but I'm speaking that as
a dressmaker they gave us an inch and it
wouldn't take a yard
and it's not it's not helping us it's
not helping us and we've gone from being
able to work being able to vote to I'm
the same as a man I'm not the same as a
man I can't do the same as a man I need
not need men I need men
I would say that is make his day I need
my man just as much as he needs me if
not more but that's what's changed is
that nowadays
the feminism the feminists think that
they need that they don't need men
but if they didn't meet men
where would we be
so I'm a feminist that
in the old school days I I like what
I've been given I've been given an inch
I'm happy with an inch I don't want the
yard I can't handle the yard so me I'm
okay working taking care of my man
and being feminine and I think the
feminists have taken
feminism out of the word feminist it's
to do with being an empowered woman not
being
an empowered masculine woman and I think
that most of the feminists nowadays
they're Butch they're masculine even if
they look feminine and they think that
they're feminists they've got this on
the lion I'm the same as mental equal
and you're not you know what women hold
back know your place hold your corner
that's my view 100
thank you all right cool so the whole
feminism thing I wouldn't call myself a
feminist I would say that I believe in
equal opportunities but if you really
want equal opportunities it has to be
full-time not just when it suits you I
think uh a lot of a lot of the ideology
of of feminism is is kind of just like
catered to empowering women and like at
the end of the day a lot of a lot of
times in in reality women don't even
want to be on the same equal playing
field as men because they don't want to
take on certain responsibilities that
men take on so do I think uh you know
people should be paid the same money if
they do the same job of course do you
know what I'm saying and everybody
should have the same equal rights as
human beings but it has to be in all
aspects of life not just when it suits
you so no I wouldn't say I'm a feminist
but I do believe in equality between
races
raises or sixes
yeah races and Sixers I've got a lot of
things going on in my mind at the same
time
feminism and racism mixed up yeah right
sexiest genders or everything
2023 version of the dictionary what is
feminism because I think opinions and
positions come into what we believe in
feminism to be because as you said it's
different from the old school to the new
school I would say am I a feminist
ah not by choice
I'd say that I have to do what I have to
do and I have to get by and I can't
necessarily uh stay in my lane and I
can't necessarily not take up a
masculine role because there is no man
in my life to take up that masculine
role so sometimes I have to step out of
my femininity and adopt some masculinity
in order to get by so does that mean
that I sabotage my femininity and does
that mean that I'm not feminist because
I have to do things outside of what
technically is a feminist I ain't sure
so I think I'm I'm on the fence right
now so I'm a bit confused you said you
you step into your masculinity because
you don't have a man in your life
because if we're gonna go for old school
look after your man and he does the
manly roles and he does the car and he
takes out the bins and he does all the
masculine things at the old school
feminists might say if if a person is
because old school there was you know
husband and wife there was not so many
single women like myself right running
households running businesses paying for
cars getting under the Bonnet all of
those things what I'm saying is
sometimes if I were to stick to Old
School feminine ways
I wouldn't get by okay okay I understand
that's what I'm trying to say
um Auntie did you have something to say
I don't understand what she's coming
from so okay so you were saying that old
school you look after your man yeah and
you know your place yeah but in your
place what's the limits of that place
there's no limits it's just that is
a position that you're holding yeah
you're holding that stance I'm a woman
that's my place right so okay so what do
you okay maybe I need to understand then
what's a man's place a man's place is to
um look after me make sure he's got my
best interests at heart and he has to
make the final decision which improves
both of us he is final decision we're
always being my benefit so when he's not
there to look after you who's looking
after you I make sure I've I've got a
man so any decision I make even me for
me being on the podcast I wouldn't be
here if it wasn't for him
because before I decided to come on the
podcast
I ask his permission people I think
that's really strange I said what is
your permission would you think about it
this is what I'm gonna do and there's
certain things he didn't like so I told
Pearl you know what I can't do this I
can't do that I can't do whatever and
then we came to a conclusion but the
final decision is always his and I trust
him with it because he'll always have my
best interests at heart and I'm a
trained mechanic and maybe that's
because you've got a good man yeah wait
hold on even if you're a good man that
sounds ridiculous yeah maybe because I
can't I can't do what you just I can't
do what you just said I can't because
why would you need permit like there
might be boundaries within the
relationship so for instance like I
don't want you to do like a pearl like
strip show dance thing with like male
strippers like I can understand that
because that's like boundaries of the
relationship but in terms of like I need
your permission to do a show because I
like if your boyfriend or husband or
whatever if he's not like in this world
you probably know better than he does
like what's better for you I'd imagine
but the thing is both not in this world
we both don't know about social media he
didn't and it's blown up well you're in
this world now right right yeah but I
still had his permission so there might
be certain things that have developed
since me being on the podcast that he
doesn't agree with so I will cut them
back I mean if you pick a good guy I
mean he's a good guy yeah but imagine if
he didn't have a good guy yeah
and also you never know if you have a
good guy until until you don't believe
that don't you know yourself better than
anyone no not necessarily because I'm
I'm human I've got bad things and I've
got good things I'm just as bad as
anybody else and I will always take
other people's opinions and then when he
says something I don't always take it as
hard as Pearl knows because thanks to
pearls you know sort of their food pure
problems we've had to like you know stop
like being stubborn but you've given
another few minutes
sorry can I understand
um Auntie what you said is the exact
same situation with me I have a fiance
and I would not come up here unless I've
spoken to him about it and he's actually
agreed with it so the only reason why
I'm sitting as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible